this was the first date I went on after
being an in five relationship there were
no apps like I I didn't know any of how
this world worked so I had texted with
this girl I was like hey I lived in a
really nice condo middle of the day so I
wasn't trying to be you know sketchy or
whatever so she just shows up at my door
we have probably the most awkward weird
exchange like I don't know what to talk
to you about anything and then she was
like hey do you have any food and I was
like yeah I've got like leftovers I like
literally heated up leftovers I gave her
a plate she ate it like she was hungry
that was my first online dating exchange
and I was like this process is broke how
did you kick her out she finished yeah
she finished and then left